>> AND NOW A MESSAGE FROM AMC
THEATERS.
♪♪♪
>> IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
>> FOR THE PAST YEAR, THE ROADS
HAVE BEEN A LITTLE EMPTY.
BUT WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THE
PROMISE OF A NEW DAY.
♪♪♪
>> YO, I'M VIN DIESEL.
FOR MORE THAN 100 YEARS THERE'S
BEEN ONE PLACE WHERE WE ALL CAME
TOGETHER TO BE ENTERTAINED, THE
MOVIES.
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE IT, THE
POPCORN, THE PREVIEWS, THE
PRETZELS AND DON'T FORGET THE
MOVIES.
I'M TALKING, THE TICKETS, THE
BUTTER.
IT'S REALLY AMAZING.
WE'VE BEEN HOME FOR TOO LONG.
IT'S TIME WE GET BACK TO THE
CARPETS, THE CUP HOLDERS, THE
ARMRESTS, THE NAPKINS.
WHEN THE MOVIE'S NOT LOUD
ENOUGH, WHEN THE MOVIE'S A
LITTLE TOO LOUD.
I GUESS YOU COULD SAY THERE'S
SOMETHING FOR EVERYBODY, ONLY AT
THE MOVIES.
♪♪♪
>> AMC IS PROUD TO PARTNER WITH
VIN DIESEL TO WELCOME AUDIENCES
BACK TO SEE "FAST 9" THE WAY IT
WAS MEANT TO BE SEEN, ON THE BIG
SCREEN AT AMC THEATERS.
>> THE STRAWS, THE STICKY
FLOORS, $8 BOTTLE OF WATER, THE
NACHOS, THE HAND DRYER IN THE
BATHROOM THAT'S LOUDER THAN A
CHOO CHOO TRAIN.
THE SECOND CONCESSION STAND
THAT'S NEVER BEEN OPEN.
THE LITTLE BOY AT THE URINAL
WITH HIS PANTS ALL THE WAY DOWN.
THE BIRD THAT'S TRAPPED INSIDE
THE LOBBY.
IT'S TRULY INCREDIBLE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE MOVIES.
THE BUTTER MACHINE THAT SHOOTS
OUT SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE BUTTER, THE AEROSMITH
ARCADE GAME.
THE GARBAGE THAT HAS A HOLE
THAT'S A LITTLE TOO SMALL TO PUT
YOUR GARBAGE IN.
THAT'S THE MOVIES.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A MOVIE?
IT'S AMAZING, THE MUSIC, THE
HEAVY DOORS.
THE PRESHOW VIDEO WHERE YOU'RE
ON A ROLLER COASTER.
THE LITTLE TRIVIA GAME ON SCREEN
BEFORE THE MOVIE.
YOU HAVE TO BE PRETTY DUMB TO
GET THE ANSWER WRONG, AND I
ALWAYS DO.
ARE THE MOVIES BACK?
YOU TELL ME.
THE STORIES, THE WAY THE HALLWAY
STINKS, THE WAVING TO YOUR DAD
TO SHOW HIM WHERE YOU'RE SITTING
IN THE THEATERS, THE SNACKS YOU
HIDE IN YOUR MOM'S PURSE.
YES, MA'AM
THE WEIRD FEELING YOU GET WHEN
YOU SEE A MOVIE EARLY IN THE DAY
AND YOU COME OUTSIDE AND THE
SUN'S STILL OUT.
WEIRD.
THE CARDBOARD CUTOUTS.
THE TAKING A PICTURE WITH
GARFIELD SO YOU CAN REMEMBER YOU
SAW GARFIELD.
THAT'S THE MOVIES.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK.
>> YEAH.
WE ACTUALLY DO REQUIRE YOU TO
WEAR A MASK INSIDE.
>> IT'S TIME TO GO HOME.
WATCH A MOVIE AT HOME WITH NO
MASK.
IT'S AMAZING.